we are now live everywhere Jasmine how
you doing pile of noisy people we got a
few people on Twitter joining us
Facebook is either the internet is it
picking up or no because Facebook is
moving really slow anyway it's hey how
you guys doing um haven't done a live
for a while by the way we can do a
callin or no can they call in are we
gonna host their phone numbers and we'll
call a few people we can call few people
okay post your numbers with your
questions I'm gonna call a few guys
we'll have a conversation here together
we have a heart stop we do have a hard
stop at what time conference call with
the lawyers at 5:05 Cotabato Facebook's
giving me challenges I'm just gonna deal
with this if you can figure this one out
if now go grab the iPad because this
one's giving me challenge my attention
is gonna be mainly by a timid end stuff
DVD insta and Twitter so uh strange
times how we're living it really strange
times weird times exciting times I can
tell you for us these are by far been
the greatest times for us these are very
very good times right now for business
and I know a lot of you guys are also
doing good as well preparing for when
this thing goes away this whole
coronavirus thing that we're all we're
all dealing with when this goes away big
things I foresee a lot of big things
taking place just go to Facebook we'll
figure it out because this one you're
Mario this computer when you own a
computer from 1942 that is powered by
the entire city of Texas the city of
Dallas you're gonna have problems
okay it's all good so questions post
your questions put a phone number I want
to call you by the way tomorrow what
time are we doing this your next moves
9 a.m. Central Standard Time 10 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time I am launching a
chapter of this book that what I want to
share which I can't wait for that by the
way for you guys to get a chapter this
book by the word for all of you that
I've ordered the book thank you for
doing that many of you guys have already
pre-ordered the challenge with
pre-orders the following we've had
multiple conversations with Simon &
Schuster I'm telling you guys right now
so upfront you know their challenge
right now why they're not launching a
lot of books is because the printers are
not printing at the pace they did before
which means if you don't pre-order your
books when the book comes out on August
18th you won't be one of the first to
get the books that's probably gonna take
a you know two weeks six weeks for the
books to be shipped out to you because
it was taking place but tomorrow at 9:00
a.m. Central Standard Time 10:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time I'm doing a launch
where I'm sharing a chapter with this
book with you in a one-hour live that I
did one hour video that I destroyed
strategy-wise
on how you can get your strategies for
the book necks and and also tomorrow let
me see that covers well we're gonna have
20 20 people that are gonna get the
sleeve of the book signed
sent your way only 20 you'll be the
first 20 that get this I'll announce
this tomorrow that's pretty sick to put
on the wall by the way at the office and
this is not gonna go to everybody it'll
only 20 people that have this sign going
to them so having said that we have
Facebook live as well I think we do here
in a minute
post your questions put your numbers I'm
gonna dial you and we'll go from there
and I'll go one at a time with whoever's
got the best question people are asking
how can I get the book you can get out
on Amazon just go to Amazon type in your
next five movies you'll be able to get
at Facebook you're joining us as well we
got a bunch of different people here we
got Instagram we got Twitter we got
Mario we got Adam we got Kai here and we
got Facebook here Francisco Selena a
bunch of different guys so who wants to
do a call first we got Instagram here
when do you wake up and wise exercise
and business so critical do we take that
one what do you think Mario when do I
wake up I just finished doing the
impossible I have questions okay I am
calling apps on end you have questions
let's call out Sonny here all right AB
Sonny other we have Sonny is a Persian
name let's see if this person is Persian
first call f Sunday hello is this AB
Sunday yes Elsa how are you I'm doing
wonderful how are you I am doing
wonderful as well where you based out of
I've been Houston Texas area working
with Taz agency Valentino Martinez I
love it ok so what's on your mind tell
me what you're thinking about what's on
your mind a very simple but gave me a
lot of insight and I think I'm looking
at the the challenges right now I would
say the hardest one being can you talk a
little bit about law number 10 breaking
away from the old you oh that's a tough
one to do because you've been to you you
for a long time how are you by the way I
am 20 years old oh my gosh when I was 20
years old you could only find me out
one-play seven days a week and it wasn't
business at 20 years old I was barely
getting out of the army I woke up every
day at 4:30 we had formation we trained
we worked all day at the motor pool and
then after motor pool would come back
and we trained a little bit more and
then we go to night clubs seven days a
week I was one of the most committed
guys to partying but at 20 years old to
break away from the old you at 20 years
old is not easy because everybody around
you is telling you to live a certain
life everybody around you is pressuring
you to meet the criterias of what it is
to be 20 but once I got out and I got
very clear about who I wanted to be
because everything at there at the
foundation of everything which is the
first three chapters of this book your
next five moves the foundation of your
next five moves is who you want to be I
think a lot of times we forget who we
want to be and we do what our parents
want us to be we go do what our family
wants us to be our friends wants us to
be and we don't do what we want to do so
for me once I got clear at
age of 21 22 23 it was game over for me
and it's just not a life I wanted to
live I didn't want to live the regular
life I wanted to go out and do something
big with myself so won't be easy and the
chances of you doing it will be slim I'm
talking 5 to 10 percent but if you do it
the life you live will be absolutely
magical while you look back saying I'm
so glad I made a decision to do so
absolutely I'm looking forward to seeing
what you'll do with your life in the
next 5-10 years and hopefully one of
these days we'll get a chance to meet
you I look forward to it take care of
yourself wife wife Oh bye bye Patrick
yes okay next let's see Facebook how you
doing facebook is with us Mario just so
you know they're not in spirit they're
actually with us on Facebook which is
always good Nadeem says I need $20,000
please I beg me that is laughing because
of the boat but about tennis I got to
tell you guys for some of you guys are
watch today's video I posted responding
to a censorship a lot of guys were
asking me about censorship so I made
this video because we were trying to
have dr. Mike on and after reaching out
to dr. Mike value tamers if I 10 is like
your your you're somewhat of a bully I
want to watch the comments you guys
posted on his video you are somewhat of
a bully you gave him a hard time but you
know we'll see whether he's gonna choose
to do so even if he does it without our
platform he does it on his own I look
forward to seeing that become a reality
on Twitter I want to enter the life
insurance industry but I'm 17 years old
what do I do you wait a year is what you
do
Patrick what made you want to compete
when did you realize you wanted to be a
champion okay let's call this one here's
the Tennessee I'm calling you by the way
Oh won 6-5 ain't gone one second we're
gonna call you here one six one five
it's a nashville number you know how I
know that do you know how I know it's a
Nashville I used to go to a nightclub in
Nashville called Silverados
it was a country club okay and how you
doing Alex what's the word man how are
things are Nashville
you're that excited about it I like it I
like your attitude what do you do
yourself Alex I'm actually you are as
well you guys are hogging today's live
by the way I want to do some non PHP
people but tell me what's on your mind
what's your question what are you
thinking the alternative sucks it's that
simple the alternative is a boring life
I could care less about living a boring
life what for why would I want to live a
boring life I don't want to live a
boring life I want to be in the hunt I
want to do something big I want to be
out there where I have opponents I have
competitors I have others that want to
kind of challenge me and put me out of
business I like a certain level of
competition that you have to figure out
a way to maneuver today I was having a
conversation with Adam about different
things with business and I was talking
to him about why my views about politics
you know because I had to call your city
with Dennis Prager he and I had an hour
and half call yesterday myself himself
and his wife Sue was an attorney and we
talked about running for office what
it's like to run for office and we
talked about the most annoying part
about running for office and they said
what's the annoying part I said raising
money why is raising money the most
annoying part about running for office
because if you raise money you have to
what you owe people what favors right
and when you all people favors what do
you do when you owe people favors some
of the favors you have to do for them
are not the best for everybody else so
I'm not a fan of the way politics is ran
but in the world of business when you
compete if another person has a better
plan than you if another person has
better ideas for it than you if another
person is working harder than you
improving
more than you and they beat you they
deserve the victory that they got but if
you're able to do the opposite to them
you deserve all the accolades if you if
you're able to pull that off so I'm a
guy that grew up watching sports I'm a
guy that read every single thing about
stats with competition there's a part
about this book there's a part in this
book your next 5 moves which I'm doing a
life tomorrow to top a share a chapter
of the book with you you can go to
Peabody Live pbd dot like to register
for tomorrow's live that's gonna be at
10 a.m. Eastern Standard Time one of the
things I talked about in that book is
the fact that when you face an opponent
and you face an opponent that is 10
times bigger than you 20 times bigger
than you a hundred times bigger than you
they're intimidating you're scared of
all you don't think you can beat them
it's like facing off Goliath in every
possible way this should put you out of
business
there's no way in the world you can beat
them but how do you go up against
somebody like that and still find a way
to win how do you do that how does
somebody go up against someone like that
and compete with them you can go out
there and play basketball I can play on
Sundays I play 1 or 2 against my boys I
got a six year old and an 8 year old
every time we play together on Sundays I
feel like Shaq I'm the most dominant
basketball player in my family by the
way just so you got I don't you guys
know this or not hands down I Adam is it
true it's true the truth I'm the most
dominant basketball player my family if
my two sons the 6 and the 8 will play
basketball against me they're going down
hands down they cannot stop me I have so
many unique moves against these kids I
school I school them they're gonna grow
up one day saying our dad used to school
us in basketball but I think soon it's
gonna change cuz a six year old it's got
a game here's a moral distort I feel
good at competing against six and
eight-year-olds you know makes me feel
good the fact that oh my gosh I'm check
against these guys but I maybe I go to
YMCA and I play but you know what the
guys had YMCA maybe I'll feel a little
bit good I'll see you know I can hang
with these guys but then you'll play
against high school players that are 17
years old you know varsity and it kind
of beats you up then you go play against
college you embarrass yourself then if
you go play with NBA players it's not
even a fair match on what
gonna be taking place everything about
what I did in the insurance industry was
constantly trying to compete against
guys a level above me because once you
beat the people at your level if you
stayed there for too long you're no
longer competitor you're a bully you are
a bully I want to be bullied I wanted to
beat bullies I don't want to be the
bully I want to beat the bully so
competition allows you to compete with
guys who are slightly bigger than you to
make you feel like you can hang in there
so I just want the reasons why I love
competition
everything else is boring to me we lost
our body here okay I think I actually
accidentally hung up on him okay so
let's see what's the next question that
we have a look at Facebook here Facebook
and guy said LeBron is the greatest of
all time you are delusional
delusional okay this guy says I have a
non PHP question regarding marketing a
business transition I'm only taking non
PHP questions PHP you're spoiled you
cannot get me four questions today
nothing it's non PHP Kenneth I'm calling
you Kennedy you better not trick me we
got 15,000 agents and I don't know their
names so I hope you're not playing games
with me here Kenneth I'm coming your way
I've won five two zero five two zero
area code five two they need a lot of
girl friends by ten and how you doing so
you sound like East Coast what's a 5-2
all area code that's very useful that's
East Coast to California yeah so tell me
what's on your mind I've got a partner
12th that my question to you is when do
you know the right time is to make the
transition from becoming the best
producer the guy that lands the whale
clients to
building a team and transition there
being a coach and building people
instead of your own book of ISM well let
me ask you what's your vision if I'm
sitting there with you and you're trying
to recruit me to work for your company
or if you want me to invest and be a 20%
invest in your company sell me a vision
of where your company is going and don't
don't sell me what you want to sell me
to make the money and then change your
mind what is actually the vision of your
business who do you want to be employees
do it gross revenue of 10 million
dollars and what are you doing right now
we're applying 1.7 and like I said we've
got 12 employees five offices so you
want to go from one point seven to ten
million dollars correct okay and in
doing so out of your 1.7 million dollars
where does most of your revenue come
from an office independently ran with a
leader or a great personal producer
working out of your office man what an
excellent question
most of our revenue comes from the
leader of the office I wish I had an
army of producers but wait a minute hang
tight right there listen we're learning
something together here okay
so you said most of your revenue of the
1.7 million dollars you do is out of an
office ran by an independent leader yes
correct okay so in your mind you're
thinking about chasing producers but
that office that's creating the most
revenues for you is ran by somebody
that's independent of you and they're a
strong leader that they have producers
reporting to him or her yes yeah how did
that person become a leader was worth
very little before you found him or did
you help build them into a leader so
here's the funny thing about that
individual he actually stopped me dead
in my tracks chased me down and I say
this boss humility score grabbed my arm
and he worked at a country club I didn't
know he was industry leaders for that
and I'm in the wrote area that's the one
in deepest I'm listening keep going I'm
listening I'm sorry I'm sorry so he
chased pursue me pursuiting in my heart
attack
reject reject reject if you can't pursue
me as a future employer you'll have no
luck and pursuing candidate their
clients prospects suspects themselves
and so on so I just didn't he was a
diamond the rock came to me something
the answers I like your style
one of work with you and they could do
great things together too and it took
him roughly 24 months I didn't really
know and he just lit up took off on it
and ran with this shin it's just a
tremendous business so let me ask you -
let me ask you out out of your 1.7
million what how much does he do does he
do 500,000 a year out of the one point
yeah okay that's good I figure that okay
so he is he's thirty percent your
business twenty-eight percent your
business right correct okay human is how
many how many producers does he have
reporting to him - he's got - okay does
he have the ability to help open up
other offices next question I'm really
challenged challenged it's not about a
challenge it's not a challenge think
it's got nothing to do with you
challenging him okay so your so your
challenge is very simple for me very
very simple for somebody like me you
need help with your compensation
structure is what you need help with
your comp plan is gonna produce a
certain behavior and the behavior that
you're asking about that you want is not
being taken place because your comp plan
is not producing what you want meaning
for example you you your voice
immediately want to finding personal
producers so a personal producer and the
world is to do what to go take another
good personal producer from another PNC
shop and they come to you we'll give you
a better contract we do this we do that
all this other stuff right which which
in a beautiful world to me I don't care
to get another personal producer from
another shop I care to have a great
training system in place myself where if
you come and work with me I'm gonna help
you get to the next level whether you
are in the industry or not so that's
number one number two sit down and look
at your comp plan study your comp plan
and find out why your people are doing
what they're doing why are they not
opening up an office is there an
incentive to do so
is there an incentive to develop leaders
or is it an incentive to just be a
personal Purdue
sir and if it doesn't match the vision
of getting to ten million dollars you're
not gonna get there at the time Lee at
the time that you want to get there but
if you go out there and change your comp
plan you put a couple bogeys in place
then maybe the guy that runs your office
will sit there and say you know what I'm
gonna go develop three leaders and open
up their own offices because I'm gonna
make five to ten points based on what
they're doing in their offices I want to
be able to do that so and then when you
do that you'll get your 20 offices
you'll get to $10,000,000 your income
and you have a bunch of leaders that are
doing it what are you being desperate
about they're believing you're not
leaving you
so my suggestion to you is go study your
comp plan and make adjustments to
produce the types of results that you
want because your incentives right now
are not producing the behavior that you
want that's wonderful thank you so very
much I will do detective that but my
other option with that was to grow
through acquisition and do a bunch of
roll-up I'm not a fan of that market no
okay why why not so so okay so let's
just say if I do it say you go out there
and do it with the acquisition and you
get a bunch of people I roll up that
doesn't mean you know how to build
leaders that doesn't me you know how to
build leaders no no no let me explain to
you to you yet what is good here so when
I first started my insurance company we
had 66 agents my guys came up and they
held a meeting and they said what can we
do to recruit people away from our
competitors you know what I told them
here's what I told them why would
anybody want to work with you right now
they said what do you mean I said why
would anybody work with you would you
work with you if somebody like you
called you would you say yes yes be
honest no why wouldn't you say yes
because I don't have proof of what I
built I said great I said first let's go
show that the way we lead people works
because of our system that we have in
place once you do that then you can go
acquire because they want to come and
learn your system because it's plug and
play
then there are duplicating your system
but step number one is have more stories
of this guy that came up to you
that you build into doing a
half-a-million-dollar your income you
look for five six seven eight ten of
these guys then the world's gonna be
calling you you won't have to
bad people everyone's gonna be calling
you that's what making you got it
spend more time during this time focused
on your comp and your system and then
better I develop on leaders you'll get
to ten million in no time thank you so
very much Patrick I loved you I love
your content you're an inspiration
I appreciate you buddy have a good one
bye-bye
awesome okay non PHP right I thought it
was fair to do non PHP I let's see who
else we got out there that's got a
question with us Lou says I'm sexy Lou I
appreciate that buddy but I'm happily
married Nicole Riccardi is watching okay
let's see I never love my boys beat
games it makes them feel better and it's
true it's a good strategy okay Facebook
doesn't have any questions let's come to
Instagram here okay
Trinidad love your content I have many
questions you got a post-it for me to
call you buddy we have people from
Armenia ok did you know that you will be
successful because I do and I change
from what makes money to what I love and
do you think it's time-consuming or do I
do both Chiquito I'm calling you let me
see where you're based out up and
Chiquito if you are with PHP I want to
hang up on you as much as I love you ok
because that's the disclaimer today 24/7
I'm with you guys
ok let's see what we got here I'm sorry
the person you were trying to reach has
a boy hey your bills
one more time here you're gonna get a
run last ride here nine five nine let's
see what we got here let's see what we
got here
Shalom Shalom I just can't believe that
you are calling me and this is this is
unbelievable
i I need to start recording this I'm
just like mumbling thank you so much how
you doing great how are you I'm very
good where you based at oh yeah I'm from
Serbia but based in Chicago your
business Chicago part what part of
Chicago Airport okay nice nice so what's
on your mind tell me what's your
question yeah I have a question actually
maybe it's probably
lots of people take people thinking
about it I was in transportation English
in making a lot of money for some people
not for me and basically I didn't love
the job and then I switched to digital
marketing that I really liked and I
studied past four years and I really
think that I'm good at it and just
starting my agency past year so just
like trying to get to enough clients now
I'm making like around ten thousand
dollars so still it's not enough for my
eyes and stuff like that but for
somebody's big I just like want to see
do you think that if somebody is like
what they do and feeling really good
when they are helping people whoa at the
enginer alized
more money if you are making your own
path then if you're just like following
somebody else's need and just I go to
that like shortcut they're just like
make money okay so so so let me unpack
the question and see if I understand
what you're saying because you're a
technical question are you saying do I
pursue my passion or do I go do what
makes money is that what you're asking
no yeah or are you asking do I go do my
own thing and make tank grandma or do I
go work for somebody else and learn from
him and maybe make more money what are
you asking yes yes yes so basically I
already make my money in transportation
so I have time to figure out my own
business and they go somewhere and like
learn the systems in like some bigger
firm and then just like work for
somebody else well you do you want to be
just who do you want to be who do you
want to be yourself what do you solve
the whole marketing vision of you not
something insurance but having
consultants solvent services to big
companies just to help them grow and how
can they provide the self some services
or product to their customers something
that's you so consulting services that
you can scale that's what you want to
build yeah okay
have you ever worked for somebody that
has done that where you've studied them
to see what works and what doesn't work
you know but I have the client that I'm
working right
so basically I'm teaching while I'm
while I'm working with how big are your
clients how big are your clients not
that big I'm not surprised why would a
big person how are you I wouldn't have
the onion I would never hire you you
want to know why yes okay so you want
the truth or you want me to tell you how
awesome you are
I'm calling you so you can give me the
rapture okay if I want a good thing
that'll call me mom
yeah I appreciate that that's the right
answer I like him already
okay so so here's so here's what I would
tell you look I think too many times
people think about becoming grandparents
before even knowing what kind of a woman
to marry well who cares about being a
grandpa you don't even have a girl in
your life right now to think about
marrying step number one is if you want
to build a family is one why do you want
to get married because everybody else is
getting married you shouldn't get
married for that why do you want to get
married
well because my parents are pressuring
me you should never get married if your
parents are pressuring you do you want
to get married I do want to get married
why because honestly chasing girls every
day is annoying okay I relate I
understand so you want what else do you
want to get married for I like to be
able to follow my traditions and have a
family and be able to build a life with
another person okay great what does that
woman look like here's what it would be
what are three things you're not willing
to tolerate and negotiate that if she
has you're not gonna marry well she
can't be taller than five nine why
because i'm 5-8 okay great right that
done what else is it I want her to have
the same faith as me I'm Jewish I want
her to be Jewish great well I'm not
tolerating that then when you know that
you wanted to get married then when you
know what kind of woman you don't want
to be with then when you write them who
you want to be with then you go tell the
world what you're looking for then you
go on dates with five 10 15 20 30 of
them then you see what you like what you
don't like then you date somebody for
three months six months doesn't work at
another person three months six months
works out then you say maybe I can marry
this person then you get married then
you ask the tough questions pretty
getting married then you have kids then
you God willing have healthy kids you
raise them well then they become leaders
you become a grandpa okay so now let's
go back to talk about what you want to
do you want to build a consulting
business and scale it big and do what
I'm doing but you've never been in the
company before that does consulting
you've never worked with others to see
how they're do you've never shadowed
them before and the clients you're
getting our small clients who would hire
you nobody would hire you to do
something big you want the bigger
credible accounts this is the route idea
this is the route I took there's a lot
of people on YouTube that create content
talking about the seven keys to success
the 22 keys to be a millionaire matter
of fact there's another YouTube channel
that literally I you know which one I'm
talking about
he takes 100 percent of our videos he
has a script he looks at the camera
word for word he says what I say on 20
rolls of money he says everything I say
he's got 400,000 subscribers it's
verbatim but he's reading it even guys
comment on his channel and they say you
are verbatim taking stuff from value
tainment I don't care he's doing it it's
fine that he's doing it he's shorter
right now to another guy with this
channel but he's copying it but you know
why when it comes down to credibility a
person's not gonna spend a hundred
thousand dollars to have an hour
conversation with that person because
never never build a business before I
want to follow content of people that
are trifectas they run a business they
have their own philosophies they're
engage on a day to day basis and because
you do that you get paid bigger dollars
so for you if you really want to know on
a consulting company that skills and
gets big here's what I'd be doing number
one I'd go work for another company
I'd go work for a crazy founder who's
competitive who's got an edge who's
doing very good for himself I'd watch
the hell out of what he's doing I'd
watch him super closely and ask
questions if he's staying up late and
going to a bar to have dinner or have a
drink I'd go with them if he goes to a
lunch I'd ask if I can go with them I
treat him to lunch I take him to dinner
I take him all over the place to learn
everything and when I'm watching him I
watch him for things he does right I'm
watching for things he doesn't do right
and I'm watching thinks he's not aware
of then as I'm getting more
powerful and and being more valuable to
him then I have a serious conversation
with them two three four five years
later and I say listen Johnny what can I
do to own a piece of this company and
and he tells me you wanna own a piece
this company yes what do I need to do I
want to be with your long-term but I
want to have some equity in it then he
has a choice to say what yes
or he has a choice to say what no if he
says you know you have a choice to what
leave if he says yes you have a choice
to what stay you don't have to go start
your own company because sometimes you
don't want to be an entrepreneur and
entrepreneur sometimes a pain on a bot
why not be an entrepreneur if you're
trying to solve for being wealthy but if
he says no then you go do what you want
to do then you go you build your own
practice and then if you do that because
you had an experience working for a
company or a big-time player for a year
two years three years four years five
years then people say oh my gosh this
guy knows what he's talking about my
investment banker one of the guys beast
of a guy he's worth fifty six million
out fifty sixty million dollars and a
very modest guy low-key guy no one would
know who he is
lives in Greenwich connected with
everybody if I needed tomorrow hundred
million dollars he can put a meeting
together we could raise a hundred
million dollars if we have the right
idea if I needed a billion dollars he
can help me get a billion dollars he's
that connected this guy he worked for a
company check this out he worked for a
company where for six years I'm not
gonna say - never the company because
then everybody will know who he is he
worked for to come can you tell the
attorney can we do it five minutes
afterwards just tell him just say five
thirty five honest he just tell him I
know he's gonna be ok so he works for a
company he says for six years
all of these investment opportunities
were coming up and he says all I did was
look at every single one of the
investment opportunities I would come up
I looked at spreadsheet after
spreadsheet after spent sheet after a
bitter after formula he says I looked at
hundreds of them hundreds of them of
once we invested enough CEOs of
entrepreneurs that made sense didn't
make sense that today we'll be sitting
at a meeting and he'll ask a question
where everybody will be like what a
freaking question to ask how did hell
did you come up with
question it's because he's watched so
many of them that's why if you want to
play ball go shadow and killer in that
world watch him for a few years then ask
for equity if he gives it you go make
that company a billion dollar company if
not go start your own deal okay make
sense a lot honestly because I'm
thinking I am in one year in the
business and I'm still thinking should I
go left or right and of course if you're
retiring I'll be more than about to work
for free if that's a possibility at all
just the beach from some of your
marketing team I'm to do commune work
with man i'm way too demanding way to
demand dollars so no if you work with me
every day you're gonna have to call your
mom every day every day gonna have to
call your mom you're gonna say mom this
guy makes me cry every day i mean you
don't want that kind of it's not good
psychologically it's not healthy for you
okay if you say so but still i would be
morning lunch
to speak with somebody if that's a
possibility if not i'm really
appreciated for you making constant for
all of us especially for me because i
really like your content and i'm
basically shaky right now and forget the
speak english it's all good buddy by the
way you you are always welcome to send
an email to us info at vitamin calm
we're always taking applications and
we're always looking at people to add to
the team so feel free to send an email
to us love your style by the way thank
you thank you so much use well bye bye
bye bye bye bye okay alright so while we
guys against for some of you guys that
came in late tomorrow i am talking about
my book launch your next 5 moves this
book right here if there's ever been a
time for you to know your next five
moves is right now high school
graduating college graduating you know
not not know what to do with your kids
after the pandemic knowing how to move
your business tomorrow I'm sharing a
chapter with you guys to register for my
webinar you got to go to PVD that line
we're at 10 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
tomorrow and I'm going to give 20
limited edition signed copies of this
the book covered tomorrow I'll be giving
this to how many people Mario putting 20
of them so go to Peabody dot light and
register I'll do one more question and
then we'll wrap it up I got a guy here
that's graduating I'm gonna call him up
where you at you asked
a question on Twitter I'm about to
graduate what should I do
you're the last one and I got a call my
attorney here here we go
father if you guys wondering what's
going on with the attorney catastrophic
I'm being shipped out of us they're
saying I talk to myself Dylan how you
doing hey how you doing if this Pat it
is Pat so Dylan you know you got a nice
name right that's my son's name
villains spelled the same with the white
Oh perfect perfect like Bob Dylan
exactly so what's on your mind what are
you thinking yeah I just wanted to
connect with you about to graduate from
school from college finance degree
I know college isn't the only thing so a
couple years ago I went on to mentor and
the financial planning industry where I
wanted to get my start okay walk into
his office and asked if I could intern
with them I started working with them
and it's been two years now which which
which company is this it's a small kind
of firm and I've loved it my goal has
always been to own my own financial
company so what do you want to do not
have to work you with them what have you
learned what do you like what do you not
like uh what do I like I really love
connecting with people I love learning
about investments pitching investments
I like having high-level conversations
right you know sometimes we'll go out
and we'll we'll just be out at a
restaurant or something start talking to
someone close by what do you not like
what do you not like whether we try to
give short answers what do you not like
yeah sure I don't like the retail
planning stuff I already and all that
you don't like that stuff higher level
okay so what do you want to do do you
want to do more when you say higher
level stuff you're talking about what
like leveraged buyouts LBOs what what do
you talk to my manager bigger stuff
that's right I'm gonna do more of
portfolio management stuff private
equity alternative investments I want to
start getting into that space now so who
are you studying to go there yeah who
are you studying because there are a lot
of great books and great people to study
to learn that
yeahbsolutely I'm a big fan of grade a
Leo I know you
and on your program watch that interview
competitiveness reassess suppose I just
started reading Michael Bloomberg's
autobiography great plenty of years
those are the two I'm reading there's a
good book Masters of the Universe spell
LBOs I'm Rhett have you read Stephen
Schwarzman book or no yes what it takes
yeah have you ready yes you have you
have you tried to go work work with his
team with watch them yes no I don't know
I think they're they're pretty
prestigious like they only not only but
they mainly hire like high-level MBAs
but do you know how to you know how we
got into it so you can follow the trace
that you follow think about the PlayBook
that he went you can follow that label
doesn't okay let me talk to like last
question yeah I think her this is a big
question coming so Stephen Schwartzman
if I follow his path Yeah right
he went to Yale undergrad yeah got it
started on Wall Street yeah what does
Harvard MBA yeah and worked out Lehman
Brothers so I did became partner I
believe and I sold it and that's how he
got started after Lehman Brothers she
started Blackstone right yes
so if I'm I'm graduating undergrad
finance now shut eat more of an
entrepreneur you're an entrepreneurial
pursuit right and work with my mentor
and by unit partner with the small firm
or should I go off to get my MBA maybe
work at JPMorgan or somewhere get that
big corporate experience and then branch
off into my own house how incredible was
how incredible is the guy you're working
for right now he's pretty good but it's
just really it's just a small company
right it's taken a lot of work to build
that up
no no I'm talking about if you want to
do what you want to do and it's big you
got to work with somebody that's a
ballbusting mofo you know what you know
you try not you these the type of person
you got to work with this every day you
go to work you're almost a little bit
concerned about going to work because
you don't know if you're good enough to
stay at that place I don't want to work
at a place that it's they love me and
I'm amazing and I'm the best guy I don't
want to be out of place like that I want
to go to a place that I have to up my
game I want to go to a place where I'm
uncomfortable a little bit so who is
that person that's gonna make you
uncomfortable that's where you want to
go to I don't know who that person is
gonna be for you
but you you seem like a pretty intuitive
guy you already read the right books all
the ones you recommend you've read the
right book you're young you're hustler
you're hungry if you can find a way to
go work with some of those killers that
are out there and there's many of them
in the field you're in if you can find
that do it if not if they give you a
challenge and they said go get an MBA
you ask them while I'm doing this can
you give me a job to work here while I'm
pursue my MBA and I'm gonna show you
exactly the progress I'm making pay me
whatever you want but I want to already
get plugged into the culture so two
years they want to get your MBA you
already fully vested into their culture
and then you play ball but they already
know you're not afraid of them because
they gonna want to get a guy like that
so look for me I don't have a 4-year
degree I don't have a two-year degree
the way I got my job at Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter is I submitted 100 resumes
on my resume I told my belong got a
place like this I told him I guarantee
I'll outwork any broker you have in your
office they thought I was crazy they
gave me 15 interviews out of the 15
interviews I got I applied for Goldman
Sachs without a four-year or two-year
degree Cohen would never hire me you
know that I applied to Smith Barney TDY
I applied to everybody but when I went
in I was respectful I was using a lot of
had a lot of levity humor fun but they
looked at me and they said I put me up
against anybody watch what's gonna
happen I'm gonna give you my best and
they felt it they hired me the rest is
history
so part of that's gonna be with your
ability to sell yourself which you sound
a little cocky which is good you sound
very confident on the phone you've not
once rattled when I said hurry up you
will kind of take it comfortably you're
gonna be on the phones a lot to do deals
you uh I don't know your work you think
I don't know if you're hard working or
not that part I don't know about but go
find the right person go work with that
person make your proposition to them on
why they should keep you an offer your
job and eventually somebody crazy enough
is gonna like you because you're gonna
remind them of themselves then you get
the job then when you get the job prove
yourself then the rest is history
and I gotta let you go by the way yeah
you got a body you take care
buh-bye buh-bye gang tomorrow what time
10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time go to
Peabody dot live to register
I'll be talking with you guys a chapter
to share with you be the first to see
the chapter I'm looking forward to
seeing you guys tomorrow 10:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time take everybody
love you love you love you bye bye